استووا اعتدلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسد الفرج ولا تختلفوا
فتختلف قلوبكم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ويسالونك
عن ذي القرنين قل ساتلو عليكم منه ذكر
انا مك مكنا له في الارض وااتيناه
من كل شيء سببا
فاتبع سببا
حتى اذا بلغ مغرب الشمس وجدها تغرب في عين
حمئه
ووجد عندها
قوما
قلنا يا ذا القرنين اما ان تعذ عذب واما
ان تتخذ فيهم حسنا
قال اما من ظلم فسوف نعذبه ثم يرد الى ربه
ثم يرد الى ربه فيعذبه
عذابا
نكرا
واما من امن وعمل صالحا
فلهم
جزاء
الحسنى
فان لهم جزا فان لهم جزاء
فله جزاء
[Arabic recitation]
الحسنى
وسنقول له من امره يسرا
ثم اتبع سببا
حتى اذا بلغ مطلع الشمس وجدها تطلع على
قوم لم نجعل لهم من دونها سترا
كذلك وقد احطنا بما لديه خبرا
ثم
اتبع سببا
حتى اذا بلغ بين السدين وجد من دونه ما
قوما لا يكادون يفقهون قولا
قالوا يا ذا القرنين ان ياجوج وماجوج
مفسدون في الارض فهل نجعل لك خرجا على ان
تجعل بيننا وبينهم سدا
قال ما مكني
فيه ربي خير
فاعينوني
بقوه اجعل بينكم وبينهم ردما
اتوني زبر الحديد
حتى اذا ساوى بين الصدفين قال انفخوا
حتى اذا جعله نارا قال اتوني افرغ عليه
قطرا
فما اسطاعوا ان يظهروه وما استطاعوا له
نقبا
قال هذا رحمه من ربي
فاذا جاء
وعد ربي جعله دكا
وكان وعد ربي حقا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
وتركنا بعضهم يومئذ
يموج في بعض ونفخ في الصور فجمعناهم
جمعا
وعرضنا جهنم يومئذ للكافرين
عرضا
الذين كانت اعينهم في غطاء
عن ذكري وكانوا لا يستطيعون
سمعا
افحسب الذين كفروا ان يتخذوا عبادي من
دوني اولياء
انا اعتدنا جهنم للك الكافرين نزلا
قل هل ننبئكم
بالاخسرين
اعمالا
الذين ضل سعيهم في الحياه الدنيا وهم
يحسبون
وهم يحسبون انهم يحسنون صنعا
اولئك
الذين كفروا بايات اتهم
ولقائه
فحبطت اعمالهم فلا نقيم لهم يوم القيامه
وزنا
ذلك جزاؤهم
جهنم
بما كفروا واتخذوا اياتي
واتخذوا اياتي ورسلي هزوا
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات كانت لهم
جنات
كانت لهم جنات
الفردوس نزلا
خالدين فيها لا يبغون عنها حولا
قل لو كان البحر مدادا لكلمات ربي لنفد
البحر قبل ان تنفد كلمات ربي
ولو جئنا بمثله مددا
قل انما انا بشر مثلكم
انا بشر مثلكم يوحى الي انما الهكم اله
واحد
فمن كان يرجو لقاء
ربه فليعمل عملا صالحا
فليعمل عملا
صالحا ولا يشرك بعباده ربه احدا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين ين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر اللهم انت
السلام ومنك السلام ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ونحسن لا اله الا الله
السلام عليكم
রাব্বিল আলামিন উই
‏by
any cele of things need to
fit let see if we can get the in the box
so we can distribute it in a timely
matters
and
let's make
‏has been talking about keeping the
level today looks calm but reality
is that we need to ourselves that when
there is a no in the room or behind in
the back
it does impct the and it is really trom
so pleasে if there a no any
or ‏they should intervene they should st
in and see what they can do to eliminate
the source of noise
whether it is cle of brother or sister
ching with each other or the kids making
no so intervention in a gentle way would
go long ways to make it better
to
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
[Silence]
المسيح الكذاب
المسيح الدجال
الدجال الاعور
الاعور الكذاب
صلى الله عليه وسلم
any
‏name place
اصفهان
اصبهان بالباء والفاء
اصبهان
‏irان
وراء
riv
صلى الله عليه
الدجال
اصفهان
يتبعه
7 الف
من اليهود
700ان
‏Why is this important? What does this
me?
Well, my brother and my sister
to take this back all the way to after
all the way to the time of
مو عليه السلام prophes the
propenger
from that
‏will
come
عليه السلام
عيسى عليه
‏when
was
what they do what was their
disbelieved him
they accused his mother
and then they tried to kill him and not
just kill him anyway but to literally
execute him by hanging him on a cross on
top of a hill so that
الله عيسى ابن مريم
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى وما قتلوه وما
صلبوه ولكن شبه لهم وان الذين اختلفوا فيه
لفي مريه منهم لفي شك منه ما لهم به من
علم الا اتباع الظن وما قتلوه يقينا بلعه
الله اليه
كان الله عزيزا حكيما
وان من اهل الكتاب الا ليؤمنن به قبل موته
ويوم القيامه يكون عليهم شهيدا
الله
عيسى ابن مريم
‏willent
عليها
عجال
after 40 days 40 dark days
صلى الله عليه
‏will not spare a vagewn ority
parish except that he will enter it
except for and at the gates of which
will be the angels with their swords
drawn
and he will sweep across the earth
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
days
like
the third like
‏days will be as noral days
how days one a year second a
month the third a week how many do
we have left
standard days
but theimate that a will in
that's what is most critical to us and
that is
المسيح
صلاه
صلى الله عليه وسلم من صحيح مسلم ساد اذا
فرق احدكم من التشهد
الاخر
الاخر فليستعذ
بالله من اربعه
theell
the punishment of the hell fire the
punishment of the grave
the fitna of the life and death
المسيح
into
hand
over here et this is
a thrives on
and will be
‏Ili are not becauseer
and not miracles.
‏What important here
is what we pushing at and we will
conclude this tomorrow insallah and that
is this thing here
we have to understand
that the way we as human beings are
being controlled
is through ouresely
through the intern and the newycle
‏ando
this is little more entment
that's all
people
the
العالم MBC NBC CBS feed constantly break
next speed 24 hours a
‏need someinksob
needinks
who got up who sat down who died who
lived what happening and we we love it
we st at it with this sick desire to be
stimulated by it how many people killed
in that massac how many blown up do we
‏have video of it can I see all the bits
and pieces and we becomeed
through this the biggest danger of this
is to think that this is truth
it is not truth
it is maybe at best
95%
lies half truths misd
‏over
toy down anything
freedom of thought
soon as you say hey you know I don't
think these people are telling us the
truth are you a conspiracy theorist
you're a conspiracy theorist
‏syous n
insane cra right and are come us up
right this is this is the idea do not
question
what your what your god has told you in
the and in theone I saw it I saw it on
myone
it is a big mov that you're watching
‏But the danger of it is that when you
sit down to watch a movie, you know that
it's fiction. It's the prem of a movie
is that it is fiction.
The problem with this propaganda
is that we leave with the idea that we
have been informed of the truth and we
have not.
‏We are being told and ped lies day and
night and we having so much information
come us at a break speed we don't even
know which way is up and down anyore
and the is is that then when we get nice
and ged up we come to thej and fight
with each other fighting over what
fighting over what theone told me theone
told
‏B
how can we ever unite
how can we ever make
the quر and when we are
eyes mind ours
to garbage gage gbage
‏and teches are so
and so
and this isly whates
because need to him in he won come at a
time when people are very strong in
their he will come in a time when people
have all but disbelievedeved in everyone
‏and will come to
god people and they will him will
worship him having said that we will
this tomorrow nightال
and then after that move on to some
other issues perent to theرانing
نسالah
وكرمه وجوده
وعطائه ورحمته
ان يعصمنا من من عذاب القبر وان يحفظنا
وان يقينا عذاب النار نساله تعالى ان
يعيذنا من فتنه المحيا والممات ونساله
تعالى ان يعصمنا من شر فتنه المسيح الدجال
نساله تعالى ان يجعل قلوبنا مسقوله
صافيه اوعيه لوحيه وان يطهر قلوبنا وان
يسلل سخيمتها
اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
سنه صلاه
تراويح
[Silence]
بسم
الله
[Silence]
استووا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
كاف
ها يا عين
صاد
ذكر رحمه ربك عبده زكريا
اذ نادى ربه نداء
خفي
رب اني وهن العظم مني واشتعل الراس شيبا
ولم اكن بدعائك
رب شقيا
واني خفت الموالي من ورائي
وكانت امراتي عاقرا
فهب فهب لي من لدنك وليا يرثني ويرث من ال
يعقوب
واجعله ربي رضيا
زكريا انا نبشرك بغلام اسمه يحيى
اسمه يحيى لم نجعل له من قبل سميا
قال رب انا يكون لي غلام
وكانت امراتي عاقرا
وقد بلغت من الكبر عيتيا
قال كذلك قال ربك هو علي هين
وقد خلقتك من قبل ولم تك شيئا
قال رب اجعل لي ايه
قال ايتك الا تكلم
الناس ثلاث ليال سويا
فخرج على قومه من المحراب فاوحى اليهم
ان سبحوا بكره
وعشيا
يا يحيى خذ الكتاب بقوه
واتيناه الحكم صبيا
وحنانا من لدنا
وزكاه
وكان تقيا
وبرا بوالديه
ولم يكن جبارا
عصيا
وسلام عليه يوم ولد ويوم يموت ويوم يبعث
حيا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر سبحان
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذكر في كتاب مريم اذ انتبذت من اهلها
مكانا شرقيا
فاتخذت من دونهم حجابا فارسلنا اليها
روحنا
فتمثل لها بشرا
سويا
قالت اني اعوذ بالرحمن منك ان كنت تقيا
قال انما
انا رسول ربك لاهب لك غلاما
زكيا
قالت انا يكون لي غلام
ولم يمسسني بشر ولم اك بغيا
قال كذلك قال ربك هو علي هين
ولنجعله
ايه للناس
ورحمه
منا
وكان امرا
مقضيا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ما شاء
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فحملته فانتبذت به مكانا قصيا
فاجاءها
المخاض الى جذع
نخله
قالت يا ليتني مت قبل هذا وكنت نسيا منسيا
فناداها من تحتها الا تحزني قد جعل ربك
تحتك سريا
وهزي اليك بجذع النخله تساقط عليك رطبا
جيا
فكلي واشربي وقري عينا
فانا ترين من البشر احدا فقولي
فقولي اني نذرت للرحمن صوما فلن اكلم
اليوم انسيا
فاتت به قومها تحمله
قالوا يا مريم مريم لقد جئت شيئا فريا
يا اخت هارون ما كان ابوك امرا سوء وما
كانت امك بغيا
فاشارت اليه
قالوا كيف نكلم من كان في المهد صبيا
قال اني عبد الله اتاني
الكتاب وجعلني نبيا
وجعلني مباركا اينما كنت
واوصاني بالصلاه
واوصاني بالصلاه والزكاه ما دمت حيا
وبر بوالدتي
ولم يجعلني جبارا
شقيا
والسلام علي يوم ولدت ويوم اموت ويوم ابعث
حيا
ذلك عيسى ابن مريم قول الحق الذي فيه
يمترون
ما كان لله ان يتخذ من ولد سبحانه
سبحانه اذا قضى امرا فانما يقول له كن
فيكون
وان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه
هذا صراط
مستقيم
فاختلف الاحزاب من بينهم فويل للذين كفروا
من مشهد يوم عظيم
اسمع بهم وابصر يوم ياتوننا
لكن الظالمون في ضلال مبين
وانذرهم
يوم الحسره اذ قضي الامر وهم في غفله وهم
في غفله
وهم لا يؤمنون
انا
نحن نرث الارض ومن عليها والينا يرجعون
واذكر في الكتاب ابراهيم انه كان صديقا
نبيا
اذ قال لابيه يا ابت لم تعبد ما لا يسمع
ولا يبصر ولا يغني عنك شيئا
يا ابت اني قد جاءني
من العلم ما لم ياتك فاتبع عني
فاتبعني اهدك صراطا
سويا
يا ابت لا تعبدي الشيطان
ان الشيطان كان للرحمن
عصيا
ابت اني اخاف ان يمسك عذاب من الرحمن
وتكون للشيطان وليا
قال راغب انت عن الهتي يا ابراهيم
لئن لم تنته لارجمنك
واهجر مليا
قال سلام عليك ساستغفر لك ربي انه
كان بي حفي فيا
واعتزلكم وما تدعون من دون الله
وادعوا ربي عسى
اكون بدعاء
ربي شقيا
فلما اعتزلهم وما يعبدون من دون الله
وهبنا له وهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب وكلنا
جعلنا نبيا
ووهبنا لهم من رحمتنا
وجعلنا له لسان صدق عليا
واذكر في كتاب موسى انه
كان مخلصا
وكان رسولا نبيا
وناديناه من جانب الطور الايمن
وقربناه نجيا
ووهبنا له من رحمتنا اخاه هارون نبيا
واذكر في الكتاب اسماعيل
انه كان صادق الوعد وكان رسولا نبيا
وكان يامر اهله بالصلاه والزكاه كان عند
ربه مرضيا
واذكر في الكتاب ادريس
انه كان صديقا
نبيا
ورفعناه مكانا عليا
اولئك
الذين انعم الله عليهم من النبيين
من النبيين
من ذريه ادم وممن حملنا مع نوح
وممن
حملنا مع نوح ومن ذريه ابراهيم واسرائيل
وممن هدينا واجتبينا
اذا تتلى عليهم ايات الرحم الرحمن خروا
سجدا
وبكيا
اكبر
سجدتي
س
الله اكبر
فخلف من بعدهم خلف اضاعوا الصلاه واتبعوا
الشهوات فسوف يلقون غيا
الا
الا من تاب وامن وعمل صالحا
فاولئك
يدخلون الجنه ولا يظلمون شيئا
جنات عدن جنات عدن التي وعد الرحمن عباده
بالغيب
انه وعد انه كان وعده ماتيا
لا يسمعون فيها لغوا الا سلاما
ولهم فيها رزقهم
ولهم فيها رزقهم بكره
وعشيا
ولهم رزقهم فيها بكره
تلك الجنه التي نورث من عبادنا من كان
تقيا
وما نتنزل الا بامر ربك له ما بين ايدينا
وما خلفنا وما بين ذلك
وما كان ربك نسيا
رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما فاعبده
واصطبر لعبادته
هل تعلم له سميا
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستق مستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ويقول الانسان اذا ما مت لسوف اخرج حيا
اولا يذكر كر الانسان انا خلقناه من قبل
ولم يك شيئا
فوربك لنحشرنهم
والشياطين
ثم لنحضرنهم
حول جهنم
جثيا
ثم لننزعن
منهم ثم لننزعن ان من كل شيعه ايهم اشد
على الرحمن عتيا
ثم لنحن اعلم بالذين هم اولى بها صليا
وان منكم الا واردها
كان على ربك حتما مقضيا
ثم
ننجي الذين اتقوا
ونذروا الظالمين فيها جثيا
واذا يتلى واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات
قال الذين كفروا
قال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا اي الفريقين
اي الفريق قين خير مقاما
واحسن نديا
وكم اهلكنا قبلهم من قرن هم احسن اثاثا
ورئيا
قل من كان في الضلاله فليمدد له الرحمن
مدا
حتى اذا راوا ما يوعدون اما العذاب
الساعه فسيعلمون
من هو شر مكانا
واضعف جندا
ويزيد الله الذين اهتدوا هدى
والباقيات الصالحات خير عند ربك ثوابا
وخير مردا
افرايت الذي كفر باياتنا
قال لاوتين
مالا وولدا
اطلع الغيبان اتخذ عند الرحمن عهدا
كلا سنكتب ما يقول ونمد له من العذاب مدا
ونرثه ما يقول وياتينا فردا
واتخذوا من دون الله الهه ليكونوا لهم عزا
كلا سيكفرون بعبادتهم
ويكونون
عليهم ضدا
الم تر انا
الم تر انا ارسلنا الشياطين على الكافرين
تازهم ازا فلا تعجل عليهم انما نعد لهم
عدا
يوم نحشر المتقين الى الرحمن وفداه
ونسوق المجرمين الى جهنم
وردا
لا يملكون الشفاعه
لا يملكون الشفاعه الا من اتخذ عند
الرحمن عهدا
وقالوا اتخذ الرحمن ولدا
لقد جئتم شيئا اداه
تكاد السماوات يتفطرن منه وتنشق
الارض
وتنشق
الارض وتخر الجبال هدا
ان دعوا للرحمن
ولدا
وما ينبغي
للرحمن
ان يتخذ ولدا
ان كل من في السماوات والارض الا ات
الرحمن عبدا
لقد احصاهم وعدهم عدا
وكلهم اتيه
يوم القيامه فردا
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سيجعل لهم
الرحمن ودا
فانما
يسرناه بلسانك
فانما يسرناه بلسانك لتبشر به المتقين
لتبشر
المتقين وتنذر
به قوما لدا
وكم اهلكنا قبلهم من قرن هل تحس منهم هل
تحس منهم من احد او تسمع لهم ركزا
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
لا
خمس دقائق
يلا
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل استو
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طه ما انزلنا عليك
القران لتشقى الا تذكره لمن يخشى
تنزيلا
ممن خلق السماء تنزيلا
ممن خلق الارض والسماء السماوات العلى
الرحمن على العرش استوى
له ما في السماوات وما في الارض وما
بينهما وما تحت الثرى وان تجهر بالقول
فانه يعلم السر واخفاه
الله لا اله الا هو له الاسماء
الحسنى وهل هل اتاك حديث موسى
اذ راى نارا فقال لاهلهم كثوا اني انست
نارا لعلي اتيكم
منها
لعلي اتيكم منها بقبس او اجد على النار
هدى فلما
اتاها نودي يا موسى
اني انا ربك فاخلعن عليك انك بالواد
المقدس طوى وانا اخترتك فاستمع لما يوحى
انني انا الله
الا انا فاعبدني واقم الصلاه لذكري
ان الساعه اتيه اكاد اخفي فيها
لتجزى كل نفس
بما تسعى فلا يصدنك
عنها من لا يؤمن بها واتبع هواه فتردى
وما تلك بيمينك يا موسى
قال هي عصاي اتوكا عليها واهش بها على
غنمي ولي فيها مارب اخرى قال القها يا
موسى فالقاها فاذا هي حيه
تسعى
قال خذها ولا تخف سنعيدها سيرتها الاولى
واضمم يدك الى جناحك تخرج بيضاء
من غير سوء ايه اخرى
لنريك من اياتنا الكبرى
اذهب الى فرعون انه
طغى قال رب اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي امري
واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي
واجعل لي وزيرا من اهل هارون
اشدد به ازري واشركه في امري كي نسبحك
كثيرا ونذكرك كثيرا
انك
كنت بنا بصيرا
قال قد اوتيت سؤلك يا موسى ولقد مننا عليك
ولقد منم
عليك مره اخرى اذ اوحينا الى امك ما يوحى
ان اقذ فيه التابوت فاقذ فيه اليم فليلقه
اليم بالساحل
ياخذه عدو لي وعدو له والقيت عليك محبه
مني
ولتصنع على عيني اذ تمشي اختك فتقول هل
ادلكم على من يكفله فرجعناك الى امك كي
تقر عينها ولا تحزن وقتلت نفسا فنجيناك من
الغم وفتناك
فتونا
فلبثت سنين في اهل مدين ثم
جئت على قدر يا موسى واصطنعتك لنفسي اذهب
انت واخوك باياتي ولا تنيا في ذكري اذهبا
الى فرعون انه طغى
قال ربنا اننا نخاف ان يفرط علينا او ان
يطغى ق له
[Arabic recitation]
لعله يذكر لعله يتذكر او يخشى
قال ربنا اننا نخاف ان يفرط علينا او ان
يطغى قال لا تخافا انني
معكم ما
انني
معكما اسمع وارى فاتياه فقولا انا رسول
ربك فارسل معنا بني اسرائيل ولا تعذبهم
قد جئناك بايه من ربك والسلام على من اتبع
الهدى قال والسلام على من اتبع الهدى
انا قد اوحي الينا ان العذاب على من كذب
وتولى
قال فمن ربكما يا موسى قال ربنا الذي اعطى
كل شيء خلقه ثم هدى قال فما بال القرون
الاولى قال علمها عند ربي في كتاب
لا يضل ربي ولا ينساه
الذي جعل لكم الارض مهدا وسلك لكم فيها
سبلا
وانزل
من السماء
ماء
فاخرجنا
فاخرجنا به ازواجا من نبات
شتى كلوا وارعوا انعامكم
ان في ذلك لايات
لاولي النه
وفيها نعيدكم
ومنها نخرجكم تاره
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد اريناه اياتنا كلها فكذب وعصاه
قال جئتنا لتخرجنا من ارضنا بسحرك يا موسى
فلناتينك
بسحر مثله فاجعل بيننا وبينك موعدا لا
نخلفه نحن ولا انت مكانا سواى قال موعدكم
يوم الزينه وان يحشر
الناس ضحا فتولى فرعون فجمع كيده ثم اتاه
قال لهم موسى ويلكم لا تفتروا على الله
كذبا فيسحتكم
بعذاب
وقد خاب من افترى فتنازعوا امرهم بينهم
واسروا
النجوى
قالوا ان هذان لساحران يريدان ان يخرج
رجاكم من ارضكم بسحرهما
ويذهبا بطريقتكم
المثلى فاجمعوا كيدكم ثم اتوا صفا وقد
افلح اليوم من استعلى
قالوا يا موسى اما ان تلقي واما ان نكون
اول من القاه فالقوا حبالهم وعصيهم
قال بل القوا فاذا حبالهم وعصيهم يخيل
اليه من سحرهم انها تسعى فاوجس في نفسه
خيفه موسى قلنا لا تخف انك
انت الاعلى
والق ما في يمينك تلقف ما صنعوه
انما صنعوا كيد ساحر ولا يفلح الساحر حيث
اتاه فالقي السحره سجدا
قالوا امنا برب هارون وموسى
قال امنتم له قبل ان اذن
انه لكبيركم الذي علمكم السحر فلاقطعن
ايديكم وارجلكم من خلاف
ولاصلبنكم
في جذوع النخل ولتعلمن
اشد عذابا
وابقى
قالوا لن نؤثرك على ما جاءنا من البينات
والذي فطرنا
فاقضنا ان تقاض
انما
تقضي هذه الحياه الدنيا
انا امنا بربنا ليغفر لنا خطايانا
ليغفر لنا خطايانا وما اكرهتنا
عليه من السحر والله خير
وابقى انه من يات ربه مجرما فان له جهنم
فان له جهنم
لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
ومن ياته مؤمنا قد عمل الصالحات فاولئك
فاولئك
لهم الدرجات العلى جنات عدل تجري من تحتها
الانهار
خالدين فيها وذلك جزاء
من تزكاه
ولقد اوحينا الى موسى ان اسر بعبادي
واضرب لهم طريقا في البحر يبسا لا تخاف
دركا ولا تخشى فاتبعهم فرعون بجنوده
فغشيهم من اليم ما غشيهم
واضل فرعون قومه وما هدى يا بني اسرائيل
قد انجيناكم
من عدوكم
وواعدناكم
جانب الطور الايمن ونزلنا عليكم المن
والسلوى
كلوا من طيبات ما رزقناكم
ولا تطغوا فيه ولا تطغوا فيه فيحل عليكم
غضبي ومن يحلل عليه غضبي فقد هوى
واني لغفار لمن تاب
واني لغفار لمن تاب وامن وعمل صالحا
ثم
اهتدى
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واني لغفار لمن تاب وامن وعمل صالحا ثم
اهتدى وما اعجلك عن قومك يا موسى قالهم
اولئ على اثري وعجلت اليك ربي لترضى قال
فانا قد فتنا قومك من بعدك واضلهم
السامرين
فرجع موسى الى قومه غبان اسفا قال الم
يعدكم ربكم وعدا حسنا افطال عليكم العهد
ام اردتم ان يحل عليكم غضب من ربكم
فاخلفتم موعدي
قالوا ما اخلفنا موعدك بملكنا ولكن حملنا
اوزارا من زينه القوم فقذفناها
فقذفناها فكذلك القى السامري
فاخرج لهم عجنا جسدا له خوار فقال هذا
الهكم واله موسى فنسيه
فاخرج فاخرج لهم عجلا جسدا له خوار فقالوا
هذا الهكم واله موسى فنسي
افلا يرون الا يرجع اليهم قولا ولا يملك
لهم ضرا ولا نفعا ولقد قال لهم هارون من
قبل يا قوم انما فتنتم
به وان ربكم الرحمن
وان ربكم الرحمن فاتبعوني واطيعوا امريوا
لن نبرح عليه عاكفين حتى يرجع الينا موسى
قال يا هارون ما منعك اذ رايتهم ضلوا الا
تتبعني افعصيت امري قال يا ابن ام لا تاخذ
بلحيتي ولا براسي اني خشيت ان تقول فرقت
بين بني اسرائيل
ولم ترقب قولي
قال فما خطبك يا سامري
قال بصرت بما لم يبصروا به فقبضت قبضه من
اثر الرسول فنبذتها وكذلك سولت لي نفسي
قال فاذهب فان لك في الحياه ان تقول لا
مساس
وان لك موعدا لن تخلفه وانظر الى الهك
الذي ظلت عليه عاكفا لنحرقنه
ثم لننسفنه
انه في اليم نسفا
انما الهكم الله الذي لا اله الا هو وسع
كل شيء علما
كذلك نقص عليك من انباء ما قد سبق وقد
اتيناك من لدنا ذكر من اعرض عنه فانه يحمل
يوم القيامه
وزرا خالدين فيه
وساء لهم يوم القيامه حملا يوم ينفخ في
الصور ونحشر المجرمين يومئذ زرقا يتخافتون
بينهم ان لبثتم الا عشرا نحن اعلم بما
يقولون اذ يقول امثلهم طريقه ان لبثتم الا
يوما
ويسالونك عن الجبال فقل ينسفها
ربي نسفا فيذرها قاعا صفصفا لا ترى فيها
عوجا
ولا انت يومئذ يتبعون الداعي لا عوج له
وخشعت الاصوات للرحمن فلا تسمع الا همسا
يومئذ لا تنفع الشفاعه الا من اذن له
الرحمن
الا من اذن له الرحمن ورضي له قولا يعلم
ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم ولا يحيطون به
علما
وعنت الوجوه للحي القيوم
وقد خاب من حمل ظلما ومن يعمل من الصالحات
وهو مؤمن فلا يخاف ظلما ولا هضما
وكذلك انزلناه قرانا عربيا
وصرفنا فيه من الوعيد
وصرفنا فيه من الوعيد لعلهم يتقون او يحدث
لهم ذكر فتعالى الله الملك الحق ولا تعجل
بالقران من قبل ان يقضى اليك وحيه وقل رب
زدني علما
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد عهدنا الى ادم من قبل فنسي ولم نجد
له عزما واذ قلنا للملائكه
اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس ابى فقلنا
يا ادم ان هذا عدو لك ولزوجك فلا يخرجن
انكما
الجنه فتشقى ان لك الا تجوع فيها ولا تعرى
وانك لا تظما فيها ولا تضحى
فوسوس اليه الشيطان قال يا ادم هل ادلك
على شجره الخلد وملك لا يبلى
فاكلا منها فبدت لهما سوءاتهما وطف قا
يخصفان عليهما من ورق الجنه
وعصى
ادم ربه فغوى
ثم اجتباه ربه فتاب عليه وهدى
قال اهبطا منها جميعا بعضكم لبعض عدو
فاما ياتينكم
مني هدى
فمن اتبع هداي فلا يضل ولا يشقى ومن اعرض
عن ذكري فان له معيشه
ضنكا ونحشره يوم القيامه اعمى
قال رب لم حشرتني اعمى وقد كنت بصيرا قال
كذلك اتتك اياتنا فنسيتها وكذلك يوم تنسى
وكذلك نجزي من اسرف ولم يؤمن بايات ربه
ولعذاب الاخره اشد وابقى
افلم يهد لهم كم اهلكنا قبلهم من القرون
يمشون في مساكنهم
ان في ذلك لايات لاولي النهى ولولا كلمه
سبقت من ربك لكان لزاما واجل مسمى
فاصبر على ما يقولون وسبح بحمد ربك قبل
طلوع الشمس وقبل غروبها
ومن اناء الليل فسبح واطراف النهار لعلك
ترضى
ولا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به ازواجا
منهم زهره الحياه الدنيا لنفتنهم فيه
ورزق ربك خير وابقى وامر اهلك بالصلاه
واصطبر عليها لا نسالك رزقا نحن نرزقك
والعاقبه للتقوى
وقالوا لولا ياتينا بايه من ربه اولم
تاتهم بينه ما في الصحف الاولى ولو انا
اهلكناهم بعذاب من قبله لقالوا
لقالوا ربنا لولا ارسلت الينا رسولا فنتبع
اياتك من قبل ان نذل ونخزى
قل متربص فتربصوا
فستعلمون من اصحاب الصراط السوي ومن اهتدى
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الشفع والبتر
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا ايها الكافرون لا اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد لكم دينكم
ولي دين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك اللهم لنا فيما
اعطيت وقنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك سبحانك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه
لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت لك الحمد على ما انعمت به
علينا واوليت نستغفرك اللهم من كل ذنب
وخطيئه ونتوب اليك ونؤمن بك ونتوكل عليك
ونكل اليك الامر كله
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا كلها دقها وجلها
اولها واخرها علاتها وسرها ما علمنا منها
وما لم نعلم برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين واذل الشرك
والمشركين واعل بفضلك رايتي الحق والدين
اللهم انصر امتنا على من عاداها اللهم
انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في كل مكان اللهم
انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في غزه والسودان
وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين اللهم اجمع
شمل امتنا ووحد صفوفنا
وقوي شوكتنا
واهزم اعدائنا
وانصرنا اللهم على من عادانا
وعليك باعدائنا واعدائك اعداء الدين من
الصهاينه الملاعين اللهم انهم قد افسدوا
في الارض وتولوا وافسدوا في الحرث والنسل
وانت ربنا لا تحب الفساد فعليك بهم يا رب
العالمين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في كل مكان
واغفر لنا تقصيرنا في نصرتهم يا رب
العالمين ولا حول ولا قوه الا بك. سبحان
ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل
اللهم وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
والتابعين
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
[Arabic recitation]
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحانك